i guess what what my struggle is is
you're running in florida and
what
i guess what what i you know what i'm
trying to speak to you is people people
who who came here
came here because they care about
freedom when someone like desantis said
i don't i don't i don't know desantis i
don't have any personal like he i don't
know him he's a stranger to me but when
he speaks words like school choice when
he speaks words like you know freedom
and autonomy over your own health and
health care decisions when he unless
it's an abortion abortion is a very
complex topic we could have a whole hour
on that which we don't have right now
but when he talks about schools and
parental rights in schools everybody
talked about don't say gay bill don't
say gay wasn't in the bill and it wasn't
about that it was about parental rights
those are issues that for me i'm a mom
you know i'm somebody who did not grow
up with money i'm somebody who believes
in opportunity i'm somebody who wants to
keep more of my heart earned cash
because that's that's going to be my
kids money one day
these are things that speak to me
freedom opportunity choice you spoke
about opportunity in the beginning and i
guess what i want you to sort of walk
away from this is just understanding i
don't care liberal democrat republican
these labels mean nothing to me what i
want is somebody who's going to fight
for individuals and who's going to fight
for real opportunity and that looks like
low taxes that looks like schools to
teach reading writing and math and not
you know trying to persuade you to feel
this way or that way that's not what
school's supposed to be and that's not
what they're doing either like well it
is happening across the country and it
happened in schools i taught in in new
york city and it does happen there's a
lot of misinformation about all of this
and it's gotten so out of control and
and the fact but do you do you want what
that message that do you believe that
someone like you could speak to somebody
like me and get me to vote for you of
course so then right now can you can you
tell me why i should vote for you
absolutely because the end of the day i
want to make sure that you've got a
florida that is safe for your children
in school you've got a two-year-old she
a girl a boy that's a boy hartley
want to make sure that they're safe in
school that they've got a good
educational environment that you have an
opportunity to succeed in the state of
florida that makes also that you have
affordability on housing
um and there are things that have come
into place i asked also for that tax for
the um for the gas um emergency because
the fact not only was it going to help
people at the gas pump do you support
energy independence for the country do
you support worse okay we've got to get
there i mean look what's happened i mean
we i mean look what's happening do you
support drilling you support whatever
needs to happen in order to make that
happen i support us look there's this is
why i legalized hemp in the state of
florida because hemp is going to be an
alternative to biofuel it's going to be
a biofuel it is all biodegradable
products that can be made with instead
of these little
i love that listen i love hemp we can
agree on that and we can also agree on
marijuana legalization i know you feel
that way
which is interesting i've never smoked
weed in my life i can't stand the smell
of it but i'm such a freedom fighter i'm
like legalizing it look at youtube
finding common ground on marijuana there
was no but i'm saying but like on that
that's a libertarian approach right you
know and i'm and that's where and the
truth of the matter is this
all the things you're talking about
freedom that is a one-sided freedom
decision conversation because let me
tell you the conversations that i have
are i feel like my freedom is being
taken away so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]